i woke up this morning at 4 a.m because
olive was screaming through the house
asking where i was i'm like i'm in bed
with you where
why did you not just look over um so we
get up
and we start rebinging we're so
into cobra kai right now have you guys
seen
kobrakai no okay no but i did watch
karate kid like 45 times
uh as a kid i always wanted a black belt
but the closest i ever got was one of
those reversible brown and black belts
from walmart yeah
but no so but when ralph launcher was
here i thought mental note but then we
got into bridgerton so okay i'm gonna
watch it
it's have you seen it [ __ ] no you i
it's not for me it's not
there's too much other stuff out there
well here's what i love about it
is it's so multi-generational it's like
the two
adults ralph macchio and william zabka
and they go back to their own childhoods
and they're raising kids and it's a lot
about like
how do you like get rid of your fear and
flip the script and then all the modern
kids on their phones and
there is something for everybody it's
very smart okay i trust you you got me
into bridgerton
uh i love you for that did you watch
bridgerton [ __ ] oh god
you're wearing a harness you would love
it not in
bridgerton what have you been watching
we are obsessed with the show endeavor
it's sort of law order set in 1960s
oxford england
oh yeah i watch a 90 day fiance like
non-stop 24 7. so congratulations on
being classy
all right now we're moving on to some
high heels this is interesting
apparently women
are kicking them off in huge numbers
during the pandemic
in style reports that in 2020 high heel
sales dropped by
71 can you believe that birkenstocks
uggs crocs those are up but i gotta ask
you too because as a man i'm like i
don't know what to say about this
but do you think that high heels are
gonna come back
after this i am going to defer to my
children's aunt who
if she was to go running in the park
would wear high heels can we see her
shoes now look at these
yes so have you stopped wearing high
heels at all during the pandemic
no i mean i i didn't wear them during
the day but i get dressed every day
because for me i just need boundaries
since i work from home
i can't do like that sweatpants thing i
want to like blow torch them at this
point but
i don't wear heels during the day but
sometimes for dinner i'll put them on at
night just because i don't want to lose
the power of walking in them otherwise i
think in september people are going to
be like breaking ankles all over america
just like their ankles drink people
they're gonna be like on those scooters
with their knee up because they're like
stiletto fall yeah you know i just think
people are gonna bite it because they're
not used to it i feel like
there's gonna be such an explosion of
expression
to see and be seen i feel it i do think
when we can go back to real life i'm
going to go
hard i'll be wearing sequins every
single day an excuse to go somewhere
totally roaring 20s yeah they're coming
exactly okay well next some exciting
news about a brand new show coming to
netflix people magazine reports that
michelle obama
will star in waffle and mochi
it's a brand new kids cooking show
featuring dishes from around the world
it's very global and if michelle obama
wasn't sunshine enough
check out her two co-stars waffle and
mochi
they're the cutest things i can't even
handle it it premieres march 16th
thoughts i think it's great i love
muppets in any form except for creepy
ventriloquist dummies but i love
puppets and muppets i had like a crush
on jason siegel just because he did
those puppets
yeah i think they're he wrote the
muppets movie and the music
i just i love them i think they're so
cute well i think this is a really
interesting way the fact that they're
making it global and for kids it's going
to get
kids thinking about how big the world is
and what kind of possibilities and where
they want to go and what they want to
eat
and i think that's exciting well and
this is authentic to her her whole let's
move campaign
and getting gardens into schools and
you know challenging schools to have
better food
this has been her thing for as long as i
can remember i mean we're talking
15 years she's been at the forefront
of a healthy movement for kids and so
who better
to be between waffle and mochi than mrs
michelle obama i love her and what what
will she do next
i don't know she can do anything okay
jill you have the next story
okay well valentine's day is this sunday
and if you haven't made your romantic
plans yet
don't bother we found the perfect date
fox news reports for just five bucks you
can take a valentine's day virtual tour
of the largest sewage plant in new york
city
the plant cleans the waste water of over
a million new yorkers
so if you've ever wondered where it all
goes now's your chance to find out
on valentine's day and we pay them five
dollars to take the tour
yeah honey you're my number one and my
number two
yes you did yes you
did if you brought me there for
valentine's day you know what you're
doing february 15th you're wondering
where'd ross go
well i can i can add to this which is
if a romantic night in a sewage plant
isn't your style
what about a romantic night at lowe's
fox business reports also that the home
improvement store is offering couples a
night of
lomance oh you've heard me right 50
lucky couples will be chosen to spend a
romantic evening at their local lowe's
with champagne
some light bites and their own paint
zone because they're going to get a
large canvas and some sherwin-williams
paint
to create their own work of art they
look like they just killed somebody
[Laughter]
it reminds me of another couple i know
yeah
the couple that's covered in blood
together stays together
or paint you know whatever well okay and
before we go we've got the most perfect
snack
for your your v-day into these food news
okay we talked about a meat bouquet
earlier in the week which i was all
behind and i said what
is my favorite part of the chicken you
think the best part of the chicken is
the finger
is the chicken finger right well i have
a very okay someone heard me prayers are
answered
almost a chicken finger a delish reports
that tyson just released
nuggets of love which are heart-shaped
chicken nuggets
uh i didn't think it was possible to
improve on this but look as a nugget
lover
i just like to say thank you so much and
we have them here look okay is there
anyone dipping
or and if so what's your dip well you
know they call me sauce matthews on the
streets because i'm always feeling saucy
um i think we have a ketchup which i
would never do with a nugget uh i think
this is a honey mustard and barbecue i'm
to go for barbecue i'm going barbecue
jill honey mustard oh
right i could eat human flesh if it had
honey mustard on it
oh gosh really good yum yum yum yum
right
good so good good and the kids love it
yeah oh you know what i'm going to get
these for frankie
they're so cute you could put them on
sticks too make a bouquet out of them
oh either way it's delicious and it
works
um can i just say this is so much fun
beyond
it's so nice i mean being here with you
guys this is so special
this is a perfect valentine's day for me
as far as i'm concerned
ditto good me too valentine
valentine's all the time
[Music]
you